intense période
d'activités qui provoque
la formala formation de nombreus
et puissantes tempêtes solaires.
Celle qui s'est formée
frapper la Terre avec des vents
de particules radioactives
qui se déplacent à plus
ROBERT LAMONTAGNE,astrophysiciel
- Le Soleil, notre étoile,
c'est une immense 'occasion, ila
des éruptions de matières
qui quittent la surface
et la couronne solaire
et qui vle système solaire.
- La tempête, d'abord considérée
d'importance majeure par
aujourd'hui à modérée.
Ce qui signifie qu'on devrait
éviter de subir des pannes
majeures sur les réseauxernet
au sol, mais également
des bris dans l'espace.
- Ça peut affecter toutelectron,
électrique et électronique
dont on dispose. Alors,
on parle de satellites
en orbite autour dommunications,
les astronautes dans la Station
spatiale internationale.
- En contrepartie, on prévoit
que cette tempête va créer
à la formation d'aurores
boréales très colorées.
- Présentement, ce à quoi
les voir beaucoup plus
facilement au sud.nt au sud.ntÇt
même se rendre possiblement
jusque dans les États comme
la frontière, donc on devrait
à un spectacle
assez impressionnant.
- Déjà, des auroresci
ont été photographiéesà Anticost
en Basse-côte Nord.
Et si la et le ciel clair,
même les Montréalais
pourraient en profiter
dans les prochains jours.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon